poverty conflict rights abuses
instability unemployment just some of
the factors that drive more than 100,000
people on average each year to try to
enter the European Union illegally often
in dangerous circumstances the EU Border
Agency Frontex is one of Europe's
answers to this challenge it coordinates
the measures that countries take at the
--use external borders Frontex has
conducted more than 900 search and
rescues involving some 50,000 people
since 2011 this rescue of the Italian
island of land producer is one example
many times we have such kind of
incidents at the sea but at land borders
also we've experienced also incidents
like that saving lives is one of our
main priorities I would say the main
priority the Greek Coast Guard prepares
to head out again it's a non-stop
surveillance job even in winter this
boat is working the waters of the
Eastern Aegean between the island of
Lesbos and Turkey some illegal
immigrants want to use the island as a
jumping-off point to enter Europe
they're coming from everywhere but
especially from Syria and Afghanistan
lately we have noticed that we have new
nationalities especially from Central
Africa that attempt to fly from Africa
to Istanbul and from Istanbul to the
Turkish coast and from there to the
Greek islands frontex works with
countries like Greece to watch over
Europe's land and sea borders the agency
collects and analyzes data about
would-be immigrants it provides rapid
response capabilities in times of crisis
and helps repatriate people when
necessary
frontex also plans joint missions and
ensures high operating and common
training standards we ensure that
vessels are properly equipped for such
kind of rescue operations and the crews
are properly trained and lately a budget
of additional 30 million
provided two Frontex in order to enhance
this kind of operations in mediterranean
one particular tragedy of land producer
last october has put the issue of
illegal immigration right at the top of
the EU s political agenda on the table
of European leaders calls for action
rang out in the wake of the incident in
which almost three hundred people died
when their boat caught fire and sank
within sight of land after land Purdue
said there were very strong words in the
European Union still it happened and it
is likely to happen again so now is the
time for Member States for all of us to
show that we have done our outmost
to make sure to minimize the risks of it
happening again
the task force Mediterranean was
immediately set up it's highlighted five
ways to encourage would-be migrants to
stay home and to better manage them if
they gamble on coming
one aim is to boost cooperation with the
countries that people leave or transit
to reach places like this on the lesbos
coast part of their journey to Europe
another is to provide better legal ways
for people to enter and to beef up the
fight against trafficking and organized
crime border surveillance will be
strengthened n EU countries using tools
like frontex
must show more solidarity with partners
such as Greece Italy Malta and Spain
suffering under high immigration
pressure this is what protects is doing
coordinating the Solidarity the member
state when guarding to the borders it
means that it works for all Member
States and the opposite under the Greek
presidency justice and Home Affairs
ministers are grappling with ways to
discourage people from making the
dangerous and uncertain illegal journey
to Europe
EU leaders will give more impetus to
those efforts at their summit in June